we look that's a very very very basic
complex roots all public service in fact
the particular complex numbers I gave
you were quite simple one okay so this
one is a little less simple right and in
fact I'll have you look at it you'll see
there's a extra little complicated bits
which we need to worry about okay but if
you recall right I'm going to use do
bombers theorem to try to work out one
of the different values of said because
I can replace Z over here on the left
hand side okay that's five tomorrow
syrup feed then I've got the left-hand
side in pull the form in wide-eyed form
in order to make some reasonable
comparison I need to get the right-hand
side in the same form as well okay so to
write 1 plus root 3 I in what I fourth
first I work out the modulus the modular
said to the four is think about it 1
root 3 this is 2 isn't it ok you will
get this back coming up over and over
again
okay and excuse me if you think about
where it is 1 and then plus root 3 I
wonder if you can picture what angle
you're going to get my exam Jovie to
draw a diagram point excuse me it's
radius 2 right radius 2 I've gone across
one there's one because it's circle of
radius 2 and then I go up to root 3
right so clearly because we know this is
an exact legal the one that's going to
work is 60 degrees which is cloud 3
radians ok there we go so that's why I
did it so now that I know there's two
pieces I can fill in the right-hand side
in polar form right so I'm gonna have
this the modulus right and then I've got
cause pilot three I guess it is
absolutely okay good together now I the
reason why I know this is because this
thing comes from do my research so this
let's stay back
and now I'm ready to actually start
computing this thing right I can see
straight away what the modules is going
to be because I can say are the 4 is
equal to 2 so R is equal to its epic at
all right because it's out of the form
equal to I don't take the square root or
the cube root I take that portrait right
so it's the 4th root of 2 whatever that
happens to be I should if I'm really
nice and tidy state that item did
someone jealous right so I was granted 0
because as is the whole point of this
exercise there is more than just one 4th
root of a complex number right and 2 is
in the is in the context of it okay
these are what do I do to work out the
next bit nerves lottery 2 because
remember if I take this number right and
then I multiply 4 times I should end up
with 2 but if it's root 2 and I multiply
it four times I won't end up in two I'll
end up with root 2 times root 2 times
root 2 times root 2 which is clear okay
so it won't be the modulus then I want
right
I want the number that you raise it to
the fourth power and mangoes you to just
the four three two okay yep okay yes
it's exactly what we're going to do I'm
gonna go from here you can see excuse me
this is the really important one here
right it's the cosine part there in fact
I really care now that you know where it
comes from I can really go straight to
this line I can say the four theta must
be equal to PI on three that's one of
the solutions but I can go around 2 pi
or 4 PI or 6 pi or any of those even
multiples so I should include all of the
other angles that will also work right
so why write that as do you everybody 2
K PI and I've just confused 2 K so just
anything it's a it's an integer so I'll
write that yeah
okay good I'll understand now I divide
through by four to get my my argument by
itself this is going to be K pile - okay
and I'm ready to have a think about what
my actual answers are going to be now
okay now before I actually start
computing these how many answers am I
expecting them to be how many roots of
it there are four fourth roots of a
number okay so I'm gonna go k equals
zero kick was one I'll see what values
of K will give me those four solutions
so I can say on the basis of this and
this I can now have a hyper general
statement for what's it'll be so Z is
equal to the fourth root of two there's
the modulus times probably put a square
bracket key because I've ever had this
awkward thing in the angle cause he's
the real part plus I saw it here's the
imaginary part
okay in the private you happy with that
okay now let's really quickly work out
what the actual said 1 2 3 & 4 are what
value should I test first ok here I
really started 0c okay so starting from
0 okay was your I'm gonna get z1 being
to 4th root of 2 now excuse me because
it's always going to be like this right
k play on to the first case is really
just that case right just the plain as
well so I'm gonna write that down cos PI
on 12
plus I Society well now planet won't
give you any nice exact value at least
not with the mathematics so we know at
the moment so I'm just gonna leave that
as is rather than convert it into
rectangular form I think that's quite
sufficient okay where you do get like my
angles in here excuse me like PI over 3
or pylon to apply at 6 o clock for then
it's sort of reasonable to expect okay I
want you to evaluate this and put it
back in X plus iy form are you wrong
with that right let me get the next one
k equals 1 right now as you're computing
this I want you to think I'm gonna have
one lot of plant it so I've got one
right angle around excuse me pilot 2 is
6 PI on 12 degree with that so when I
put one pine 12 here and 6 512 there the
Sun be rolled on an Annie the nanny
right pilot plant 12 plus plus plus 6 5
as well which is 7 pilot all right I've
gone forwards
you carry that so I've gone forward okay
now you can see just by thinking about
like I know where pylon to is that's the
imaginary that's the positive imaginary
axis right and I've got pod 2 plus a
little bit higher towards this little
extra angle okay
so therefore being that now let's just
roughly sketch this over here and then
we'll properly sketch it in a second
the first solution that we've got is
very close to the axis right it's like
there because that's plan 12 it's a
small angle right my next one set up
island 12 is off by a right angle do you
see that so there's my said to you can
see immediately just from here when I
add my next a lot of piyo to I'm going
to go past I'm gonna go outside the
principal I get you see that okay so
there's that one then said to I'm going
to stop incrementing up I'm gonna go to
the negative values there okay so let's
try this instead of cake was to I mean
now I'm gonna go to K equals the
negative one okay I'm gonna get my next
route which is fourth root of two tires
okay
and this time I can plan 12 minus the
same angle plane yeah good so now I'm
going to get my negative I'll let me get
my negative because I'm taking K it was
negative one okay and then I've got the
same able over here okay
now he says great about this then what's
what's great about thinking in terms of
comment right have a look at these two
angles what's the difference between
these two English well it's 512 like
this take away this is 12 PI on 12 it's
pi
isn't it of course it is because it's
exactly 180 degrees off from that root
of it end you see it because I went one
right angle anti-clockwise now I've gone
one right angle clockwise okay with that
so that's what sin 3 is okay and just
quickly go ahead you can predict zip 4
is going to do it here right and it's
going to be down PI over 12
okay so you might be able to already
great what that answer is maybe
hey equals negative two times I'm
subtracting another 6.12 right so I
should have negative very good on 12
which of course is almost at negative PI
isn't it like I'm 11 tops of the way
there so I say well okay happy times so
now you've got this kind of diagram
happening and in fact I'd like you to
draw that this is the quick and dirty
bedroom I think but you can see again
I've got four solutions as we expected
they're equally spaced out from on the
circumference and because I'm equally
spacing them out and there are four of
them there's a right angle between the
arguments of all of the different
complex roots nor nor so for example if
this was just the question this would
just be my answer that would be my
doubts are okay but I think that this is
enormous ly instructive in terms of like
okay this is like I said my cheap and
quick version right but if what about
acquis tells me if I've got my n goes in
like roughly the right spots and I don't
it's some like ridiculous number which
clearly is not one of the solutions